all right we're gonna try to keep this
little pg because there's a bunch of
kids watching mark's like
i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
[Music]
oh wow this nurse is getting it oh this
nurse is
are you watching me murder this nurse
right now no i'm murdering my own nurse
oh we're both murdering nurses what it's
time to be alive guys not during this
pen
holy sweet jesus wow look at look at
these tony hawk skills
damn roots top 6 36 jessica's body
oh she's back oh hey oh you're back are
you jessica
this is what you get for learning oh
this is lovely
oh what are you do so bob how are you
flying
mark what is the
you know guys i
am trying my best there's always so much
i can take
no you're not sad monster
there's ants killing
bob are you saying this about wade yeah
i don't know what's the deal with that
he put on the bear head and he changed
what
no
the hell do it oh we're all good yes
where'd uh wade where'd you go here
sorry oh
what is that
[Music]
mushroom
this game is complicated i see a
painting of a bear
sucking a dude's penis nose i'd want to
see
this painting oh bear sucking penis nose
there it is yellow air oh
hey oh god don't don't let him get you
he he can't because i'm gonna jet
it's not working we're going to go
stealth boys we're going to go stealth
turn the emergency lights off yeah you
don't you don't want the fire to be
prepared
you want to sneak up on the fire yeah
yeah exactly by surprise
yeah yeah you know so much about
firefighting bob
whoa we're halfway
[Laughter]
hey wait bones on the ground i like
bones bones are good for me i like bones
give them all to me
it's a cool song dude wait let me just
test something this
feels like an in-game i don't think tess
i don't think we belong here yet let me
just test something
bob do not test something bob's
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i think i'm down hey does anyone have
some sap
yes oh god i i that was piss
uh why why i drank it
wait i can drink water from this little
pond what
oh it's not oh guys i'm dying
oh good well i'm glad that i'm glad we
did that
are you actually dead oh my god
how can i make this better mark tell me
man this is a
sweep that is not shoulder it's not
weighed
yeah sweep net is not shoulders where we
really broke them
to the higher to the higher roof to the
higher roof oh
what's um happening to all the people
that work down there
i think they're dead mark there are 500
ants trying to get into the back of our
basement hang on let me take a look
oh my god
dude i am one with the ants happy i'm
curious if i'll take any damage
oh i will oh my god
happy birthday we gotta call an
emergency meeting
okay okay mark if i apologize
how would that make you feel better okay
i am sorry that your stupid naming
system has
offended me breaking everything are you
gonna
break everything
[Applause]
all right there you go yeah engine
engine gun
there you go look down for the raft feel
better
[Music]
come
our back is sturdy this will hold up oh
[Music]
cliffhanger
you